Hamas terrorists are still holding
around 240 hostages who they kidnapped
and brought into Gaza during the October
7th Terror attacks posters displaying
their faces clearly many of the children
A desperate plea for help have been put
up on walls around the globe however
anti-israel protesters have taken upon
themselves to rip them down in New York
multiple Flyers are torn away daily in
Germany police were caught tearing down
posters of hostages too and here in
London the same has happened my next
guest was called in the ACT she AB Al
Rafi REI tore down posters of the
hostages in Los Angeles and he joins me
now uh Mr Al refi why would you rip down
posters of hostages why would you do
that what's the answer because it is
perpetuating a completely false
narrative that the Israelis are the
victims of which I do not promote uh any
violence towards any innocent human
being regardless of their background or
beliefs or any uh type of of targeting
of a specific individual and those
people that have their pictures on those
posters I do not know them and I do not
wish anybody who is innocent any type of
harm it is more of a symbolic gesture
because it is pathetic propaganda that
they are putting into uh civilian areas
that we are living in and they're
perpetuating this narrative to keep
subconsciously programing people to
think that Hamas are terrorist let me
tell you what they let me not even refer
to Hamas just the Palestinian people in
general and Muslim people in general
yeah let me tell you the 11 let me tell
you the context of of where you did this
you were at several blocks down from the
Holocaust Museum in Los Angeles there
are many Jewish people who live in Los
Angeles and these 240 hostages include
grandmothers who escaped the Holocaust
they include three-month old babies they
include many children and their families
are understandably desperate for
information about where they are and
whether they're still alive and we've
already had some cases where people from
the identity on the posters they have
been identified as still alive why would
you deprive families of
that all due respect to anybody who is
suffering uh the loss of people that
they love which many people around the
world are currently suffering from but
there's always a spotlight on a specific
demographic of people because apparently
just like George ell would say some
people are more equal than others and
also a very important clarification that
needs to be done is the difference
between Zionism and Judaism Z ism is a
political ideology that is using Judaism
as a front to push its agenda whereas
Judaism is simply a religion of which my
own why don't you answer my questions
talking we're talking about 240 people
why are you laughing what's possibly
funny about because it's because it's
because if you have uh the background
information that I have about the world
in general and how politics is a game
and war is business you'd realize why
this I'm not laughing at people
suffering not at all I completely Lally
were laughing you were literally
laughing as I asked you about 2 hostages
including a 3month old
baby uh what about all the people that
are getting obliterated inaz right now
all the past years why don't you stop
playing what about it there are mass
protest what happened to the
hostage to be clear hold on what
happened to the old lady that released
and she shook his hand before there are
mass protest appreciate if you don't
interrupt me there are mass protests all
over the world Pro Palestinian protests
they are I haven't joined a
single all a single
protest but they're being allowed to
happen I would like I would like to send
a message to those protesters and
protesters around the world when you go
out into the street uh begging your
so-called leaders to do something why
don't you do something yourself why are
we why do we keep giving the authority
and power to certain pathetic
individuals who have no competence to be
in the positions that they're in to
continue having the quote unquote power
the power is within each and every
single individual which is something we
have completely forgotten and this is
how they they have people like puppets
on strings again I simply ask you many
many MERS Humanity are pathe I simply
ask you why you would rip down posters
of people who've been taken hostage
which may give their families some hope
if someone can identify them that they
may still be alive just like okay let me
answer your question on multiple layers
it's false hope number one if they
really wanted them back they'd be back
number two uh what about all the other
families that are suffering from they're
seeing their direct family getting
bombed and their entire um the videos
that I'm seeing on accounts like M's
Instagram page and many other
journalists that are there posting about
these things if I started doing that on
the street and putting his content just
take a screenshot and put it on the
Street Los Angeles and any place that is
of a civilian manner is not going to be
civilian anymore it's going to going to
be too graphic for people to walk around
on the streets and live their Day live
the rest of their lives and also another
message that nothing to do with the
question I asked you
again nothing to do with it you're not
answering the question may you're not
understanding the nuances of my
communication you know what I've got to
be honest with you uh I don't really
care about your subtle nuances or you
thinking it's all entertaining because
it's a multi-layer it's a mulay multi
layered you are walking around near the
Holocaust Museum in Los Angeles a place
I've attended
several times and found profoundly
moving and you're walking around you're
walking around there several weeks after
the worst attack on Jewish people since
the Holocaust it's not on Jewish people
2404 including 3
month je Central and your only
contribution to this is to walk around
and rip down hostage posters and you
seem to find itun my main contribution
would be to educate people on what is
really happen well let me educate you
let me educate you what you are doing is
shockingly insensitive and inappropriate
and hurtful to the family members of
those people taken hostage including
many young children and by the way I
also think the deaths of all the
children in Gaza is horrific and I've
said so many times but what you are
doing your your contrib double standard
your sole contribution to this is to rip
down posters of hostages and I find that
contempt well the interview there thank
you for your time